Traductor: Luis Uriel Angulo Zarazúa
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
¿Por qué cuando comemos
un pimiento picante
sentimos como si se
nos incendiara la boca?
¿Cómo se alivia la sensación?
¿Por qué el wasabi nos hace llorar?
¿Y qué tan picante
puede ser una especia?
Vamos a empezar desde cero.
Primero, ¿qué es el picante?
A menudo decimos que
algo "sabe" picante
pero no es un sabor,
como lo dulce, lo salado
o lo amargo.
Lo que en verdad sucede
es que ciertos químicos
de las comidas picantes
activan unas neuronas sensoriales
llamadas nocioceptores polimodales.
Estos se encuentran en todo el cuerpo,
incluso en la boca y nariz,
y son los mismos receptores
que se activan con un calor muy alto.
Cuando comemos un chile
sentimos fuego en la boca
porque es justo lo que
cree nuestro cerebro.
Sucede lo contrario
cuando comemos algo
que contiene mentol.
El compuesto mentolado
activa los receptores fríos.
Cuando se activan
los receptores de calor
el cuerpo cree que
está en contacto
con una fuente
peligrosa de calor
e intenta defenderse.
Por eso empezamos a sudar,
y nuestro corazón late más rápido.
Los pimientos provocan
la respuesta de "pelear o huir"
con la que el cuerpo
responde a muchos peligros.
Tal vez has notado que
las comidas picantes
no pican del mismo modo.
La diferencia es que
tienen compuestos distintos.
La capsaicina y la piperina,
que se encuentran en
la pimienta negra y los chiles
están compuestas de moléculas
más grandes y pesadas
llamadas alquilamidas,
que se quedan largo
tiempo en la boca.
La mostaza, el rábano y el wasabi
están compuestos de
moléculas más pequeñas
llamadas isotiocianatos
que flotan fácilmente a la nariz.
Es por esto que los
chiles queman la boca
y el wasabi quema la nariz.
La medida estándar
de picante de una comida
es su posición en la escala Scoville
que mide el contenido de
capsaicina que puede diluirse
antes de que el calor no sea
detectable para un humano.
Un pimiento morrón tiene
0 unidades Scoville
y la salsa Tabasco tiene
entre 1200 y 2400 unidades.
La carrera por crear
el chile más picante
es una batalla constante,
pero, por lo general, dos chiles
son los más picantes:
El "Trinidad Moruga Scorpion"
y el "Carolina Reaper".
Estos chiles obtienen
entre 1,5 y 2 millones
de unidades Scoville,
que es la mitad de las unidades
que contiene un aerosol de pimienta.
¿Por qué alguien querría comer algo
que causa tanto dolor?
Nadie sabe cuándo o por qué
los humanos comenzaron
a comer picantes.
Los arqueólogos han encontrado
especias como la mostaza
en artefactos humanos
de hace 23 000 años.
Pero no saben si las especias se usaban
para comida, medicina o solo decoración.
Una cacerola de hace 6000 años
llena con carne y pescados asados
también contenía mostaza.
Una teoría dice que los humanos
empezaron a usar especias en la comida
para eliminar bacterias.
Estudios demuestran que
los picantes se desarrollaron
principalmente en climas cálidos
en donde las bacterias
también son más frecuentes.
Pero el por qué seguimos comiendo
comidas picantes
sigue siendo un misterio.
Para algunos,
comer picante
es como una montaña rusa;
disfrutan la emoción,
aunque la sensación
inmediata sea desagradable.
Algunos estudios han mostrado
que los amantes de lo picante
son más propensos a disfrutar
de otras actividades excitantes
como apostar.
El gusto por lo picante
incluso puede ser genético.
Y si estás pensando en entrenarte
para aguantar el picante
lee esto:
Según estudios,
el dolor no disminuye.
Tú te vuelves más duro.
De hecho, se ha encontrado
que la gente a la que
le gusta lo picante
tienen la misma sensación
que los que no les gusta.
Solo parece que les
gusta más el dolor.
Tormenta tus receptores de calor
todo lo que quieras
pero recuerda:
cuando de picante se trata
te vas a quemar.